RETO MEIER: Hi.
My name is Reto Meier, and I'm
the tech lead for Google's
Android Developer
Relations Team.
This efficient data transfer's
DevByte is going to look at
techniques that you can use to
reduce the battery drain of
your app without affecting the
freshness of your data by
adapting the frequency of your
updates based on context.
In other DevBytes, I've explored
ways to analyze your
app's transfer profile and
optimize it using techniques
like prefetching, bundling,
and SyncAdapters in Google
Cloud Messaging.
The goal is to ensure that you
never initiate a transfer that
isn't related to require
data sync.
But if you have server data that
changes rapidly, such as
breaking news, weather, or
sports scores, treating an
update every time there's an
update on the server is still
been tax your servers and drain
your user's battery,
particularly when your app
is in the background.
Now, the aim of this DevByte
is to get beyond limiting
transfers to when they're valid
and start considering
device state, user behavior,
and impact on the user
experience to minimize the
number of updates that we
actually perform.
In my DevByte on Google Cloud
Messaging, you learned that
you can set your server messages
to be delayed when
the device is idle.
As a result, your messages will
be queued, and that queue
is collapsed, so that when your
app only receives one
message when the device
becomes active.
Now, that's a useful start, as
it prevents multiple updates
from happening when
the user isn't
actually using the device.
In other DevBytes on using the
SyncAdapter, you saw how to
group all of your app's transfer
methods within your
SyncAdapters on Perform
Sync method.
A SyncAdapter can be triggered
a number of ways, including
GCM [? TCLs, ?] client-side
changes, scheduled updates, or
user actions, like selecting
a new song, or browsing an
article that hasn't
been prefetched.
Within our perform sync handle,
we need to determine
which of these triggers are
sufficient to initiate a new
transfer, starting with
scheduled updates.
Periodic updates are a great way
to ensure your app never
seems stale, and that users
aren't left waiting for
significant amounts of data
to be synced every time
you open the app.
Of course, stale is relative,
not only to the type of data
that your app displays, but
also how frequently a user
opens your app.
Periodic updates work well for
apps like news readers, where
the frequency of news articles
makes sending a GCM message to
every app whenever new articles
are available.
Massive overkill.
And the freshness isn't critical
unless the user
happens to be actively
browsing it.
In this case, performing a
background refresh every hour
might be a reasonable approach
for users who open the app
several times a day, as it
ensures that they see fresh
headlines every time the app,
even if the device hasn't been
online for a while.
But it's wasteful for a user
who only reads the news
headlines once each morning.
Now you can mitigate this by
reducing the background update
frequency based on the
recency of app usage.
In this snippet, we check to see
if the app has been opened
since the last time we
performed a refresh.
If not, we double the period
between refreshes.
Now each time the app is opened,
we reset that counter.
So as a result, your app fresher
data for regular uses,
where those who open the app
only once a day or once a week
are saved the resulting
battery drain.
Now, if you're reducing the
frequency of updates to reduce
the battery-hungry use of the
cell radio, we might be able
to mitigate some of these
choices based on the current
battery level, charging state,
and connectivity time.
It's generally good practice to
minimize background updates
when they don't result
in notifications.
But the impact of performing
updates while the device is
charging over the AC
is negligible.
So you can reconsider some of
those assumptions when the
device is connected
to a charger.
Conversely, you can listen for
a broadcast telling you that
the devices is low on juice,
and reduce or eliminate
background updates completely
until the device is charging.
Of course, just because you're
connected to power doesn't
make your downloads free.
Even if you're not concerned
with the power drain
associated with 3G radio, you
should still be conscious of
the amount of data that
your'e transferring.
You can also monitor the current
internet connection to
help mitigate against that.
If we're connected over Wi-Fi,
bandwidth use isn't an issue,
and power use is significantly
lower than when compared to a
cell radio.
That means you can more
aggressively react to sender
synced messages when
client-side, or client-side
content provider changes when
you're in the foreground, and
potentially, even in the
background, especially when
we're also connected to power.
A good example of this
scenario is when
the device is docked.
Monitoring for the device to be
in a docked state can be a
useful shortcut, letting you
know how to check for
connectivity and charging
status, and potentially
modifying the frequency at
which you perform syncs.
You can check the current device
state each time you
receive a GCM TCL or a local
content provider changes to
determine if should actually
perform the update.
Or you can monitor changes in
the device state to alter your
SyncAdapter settings
to stop or start
listening for changes.
Likewise, you can send a message
to server altering the
frequency at which you
want to receive
this into sync messages.
For example, you may want to
receive a TCL after there are
10 new headlines, or only when
there is a breaking news story
in your area, or not more
frequently than
once every 10 minutes.
You might also want to consider
the context of the
user themselves.
Using the new activity
recognition APIs, you can
choose to alter the foreground
update frequency based on what
the user is doing.
In this example, we might
artificially limit the update
rate when they're doing anything
other than standing
still, on the basis that users
are less likely to be looking
at the screen and browsing.
Now, we can use a similar
technique as an alternative to
periodic updates.
Rather than update the app once
every 24 hours to ensure
it's fresh in the morning, you
might check for the tilting
activity after a prolonged
period of being stationary as
an indication that the user had
been asleep and has now
gotten up in the morning,
so it's worth
refreshing their data.
Now having introduced a number
of possible ways to skip or
delay transfers, it's important
to check the cause
of the sync to ensure that
you're not delaying transfers
that will affect the user
experience directly.
Any manually initiated
transfer--
so, anything that's necessary
for the user to continue using
the app, or browsing--
needs to happen straightaway.
When using SyncAdapters,
you can determine
this, as shown here.
Now in any case, while it can
be useful to alter the
frequency at which we execute as
sync, fundamentally, we're
still depending on techniques
like SyncAdapters and and
Google Cloud Messaging, as
described in other DevBytes in
this series, to ensure that we
only ever consider performing
a sync when data changed,
either on the
client or on the server.
Even then, we want to avoid
performing a sync thing that
could be delayed without
impacting the user.
In most cases, that means being
very conservative with
background updates, and anything
that doesn't result
in a notification
being displayed.